hello hello everybody gracias
i don't speak enough spanish to be able
to give this talk in spanish but i'm
happy
to hopefully read a little bit if you
have questions in it
but uh thank you so much for that
introduction um
my name is cassidy and and uh i work at
netlify and i am here to
talk about next.js with all of you and
so i will be
doing some presentations with with
slides and then i'm going to get into
some coding and i'll show you how
next.js application is structured and we
can go from there and then at the end
uh there will be time for questions and
so you can ask as many questions as
you'd like and i will answer as many of
them as i can
um so let's get started we've already
said my name i'm cassidy you can find me
at cassadoo
most places on the internet so
feel free to reach out on twitter twitch
github anything
uh at cassadoo um so first i wanted to
talk to you about why next js uh why why
would someone use
next js instead of uh just react
and next.js first came about because
um react is a client-side rendering
library you everything changes on the
client side
in the user's browser with next.js it
brought server-side rendering to react
and so when you have a next.js
application
first and foremost it was for server
side rendering where you can render
components
on the server side and then have better
seo that way
that being said um last year it's
actually just been over a year now
with next 9.3 in march last year
um they did a shift to
static sites as well and so um even
though it did support some static sites
uh in the past now if you were to use
nexjs
you could build both a server-side
rendering application and a static site
generated
application and really use the best of
both worlds and it's a
very very powerful framework there's a
lot of cool things that you can do with
it and
i'm going to talk through how some of it
works next and so
first of all what features should you
know about
when when you're actually putting a
next.js application together
there's a lot of developer experience
nice to haves
and some of those include hot code
reloading and
so when you're working on your
application it'll reload quickly on the
side you don't have to refresh the page
that's actually powered by react fast
refresh and
um in the past few days actually
next js 10.1 came out and with next.js
js 10.1
um it made fast refresh much faster uh i
i think it was something like
20 times faster so it's nice and fast
and
what react fast refresh does is when you
have an application
that um let's just say you have a
counter a very simple counter
and as you increase or decrease the
count
the background color of your application
changes
something simple like that as you change
the colors or update your code your
states
stays the same and so if i were to say
okay i really want to
check the state at five originally
before react fast refresh
you have to say okay i'm gonna check my
code then click the counter all the way
up to five
okay that's good change the code again
click the counter all the way up to five
it will maintain the state now and so
that's that's what react fast refresh
does it's really really nice
um there are some other performance
things uh along the
underbelly of the application but you
know fast refresh is is a big one to
understand for that
um there's also a lot of styling options
available with next.js
with the styling options that come out
of the box you can use styles.jsx you
can use css modules you can use less
you can use sas you can use pretty much
any styling option that you want
um you can throw tailwind really easily
you can throw in bulma really easily
it all will just work which is really
really nice
um and and so the fact that those are
out of the box
if you if you want to use it you can use
it it also has typescript support out of
the box you don't have to install
anything special to make typescript work
you just
change your file names to dot ts instead
of js
and it'll work same with environment
variables
you can make a dot end file and add
environment variables in
and it will use your environment
variables and i'll talk a little bit
more about
how those work a little bit later and
then it also does automatic code
splitting and so if there's any
javascript that you write but it's not
used on the page when you bundle up your
application
it will get rid of that code that you're
not using so that way you always have a
performant bundle
that's pushed to the browser now the
routing
in next.js is really really interesting
and um
i accidentally pushed forward so the
routing in next.js is
page-based routing so when you make a
file in
the pages directory it automatically
becomes a route you don't need to set up
for example with react router how you
need to
list all of your different routes in a
giant routes.js file
you don't need to do that it just works
when you add um
a file to that routes or to the pages
directory
there are some caveats with that and
i'll talk about more of those later too
when we're getting into the code
the api for next js is pretty simple um
these are these are kind of the four
main ones that people use the most there
there are some other ones but but uh in
terms of these ones there's
next link next link is a glorified
anchor tag it wraps around
links so you can link between pages but
what it does is it actually does
client-side transitions so they're super
fast
and so it does some pre-loading of pages
as you navigate between pages and so
next link is pretty nice for that
with nexthead that is a react component
for the
html head so you can programmatically
change your title or your meta tags or
anything like that
and that'll happen in next head um next
router is a react hook
and with that that'll let you get uh
query parameters that'll let you get the
current path
that'll let you do some redirects and
navigation that that's what the router
does and then next amp
that allows you to generate google amp
pages and so if you will have
a very article driven website you can
use google amp
um and it's built into the next js api
and the google team actually worked with
their team on that
the cli is very similarly simple there's
next
build which builds your site all
together there's next
dev dev which runs a development server
there's next start which runs
a production server and there's next
export which exports your entire
nexus application as a static site um
typically you can you you don't have to
do much with
with any of these it you'll run next dev
to work on this
on your own but it'll be the host that
you use whether you use
netlify or or aws amplifier versel or
any of the other options
um the they will be the ones running
next build start and export but next dev
is really the one that you'll be using
the most
um you can add custom configurations so
let's just say
you want more than just typescript
support you want to be able to add
other elements to it coffeescript
probably not coffeescript
but so something else if you want to add
those kinds of things to your
application
there's a nextstockconfig.js and with
that it's just
like webpack modules you can add
whatever loaders whatever things you
might want
into your next config.js and uh it's
it's fairly simple that way um now
preview mode this is a particularly
interesting feature
um and and this feature and then the
next one i talked about are particularly
interesting because they're static
first but require some node code to work
fully but they're they're interesting so
with preview mode in xjs
what this does is it assumes your site
will be a fully static website
but let's just say that you want to
preview what a blog post might look like
what a copy change might look like
something with a cms and you just want
to preview okay what will this look like
in my application great good
and then you you go back to editing it
um typically
if you do a static site you have to
rebuild your whole whole site to see
that preview and you can run a deploy
preview with that
with preview mode what it does is it
enables a um
what's called a cookie based redirect
and with that cookie base redirect it'll
actually
server side render that page so you can
see what that looks like
and then if you're happy with it then
you can exit preview mode and then
bundle your application
and i can talk a little bit more about
that but it's a it's a funky feature
and another funky feature that's similar
is incremental static regeneration
i have a lot of thoughts on on this one
isr
um but i don't have time to get into all
of them right now so i'll give you a
high level overview and i also wrote a
blog post on the subject which you can
read about and and see more details
about but what incremental static
regeneration
is is you have your static application
but let's just say that you have i don't
know
a hundred a thousand pages that you want
to render but you don't want to render
at build time you want them to
just kind of happen later what happens
is
you can have your user go to that page
you can you can go to a page that you
didn't
define statically and that page will
start to build in the background
and then when future users go to that
page it will be a part of the static
bundle
it has some funky caching stuff under
the hood in
in an ideal world it works really really
well and is awesome
sometimes in non-ideal cases it doesn't
always work and and again i wrote a blog
post on the pros and cons of this
feature but it's really really
interesting
to learn about the caching under the
hood so i will
share a link to that blog post uh in in
a little bit
that being said let's code i i wanted to
show you a nexus starter project so you
can actually take all the things that i
just told you
and actually apply it um this next
starter project
is right here it's at cast dot run slash
next starter and i'll put it in the
zoom chat as well because that runs next
starter it's on my github i just made a
little url shortener for that
and um that being said i'm going to stop
sharing just for seconds so that
i can start sharing my code and now you
can see my face
so one second as i move some windows
over and then i will share my screen
again
okay sharing all right
so we have our next js application by
the way if the font size on the right is
too small let me know and i can zoom in
um so on this left side right here we
have the basic next js
starter project and this is the one that
i just linked to
it's it's on my github on the next
netlife starter it's using create next
app that is a cli tool that you can use
for that but
it takes out some of the extra things
that are built into it and then it adds
a couple
uh nice to haves that i always use when
i start a new next.js project
and so um i will go through all of those
with you but if you click this deploy to
netlify button
it will automatically deploy that
project to your
um to to your um netlify server
and then it'll also clone that to your
github or to
whatever git provider that you use but
anyway this is this is what it looks
like
um and for those asking about my vs code
theme this is called hack the box
um anyway okay so first i will go
through some of the code and you can see
what this what this app looks like a bit
more under the hood
so first of all in my package.json we've
got the latest updated
next.js and then also react and react
dom
and that is it it is it is very very
straightforward
nothing extra beyond that it's just next
next and react that's included
um in this
index.js we have a pages directory right
here and
again if you can if you can see it i can
i can zoom in a little bit if you can't
see it but i'm going to
do this so that way
so we can get all the code in there this
is some
basic html you've got the main which is
the header right here that says welcome
to my app
you've got a paragraph and then you've
got a footer right here that
is this component right here i have a
components folder and so
in the components folder we have the
header which is just it takes in the
text which is welcome to my app
and then in the footer it's very similar
um
but with with this footer we also have
this footer.module.css and so i'm using
css modules on the footer right there
and so those are the two components that
are included
we also have a jsconfig.js you might
have noticed and if you didn't i could
show you again
you might have noticed that i used at
components um
inside of my index.js right here that's
because
something that's automatically included
in next.js is absolute paths
and so i can define my components folder
as at components and that means
wherever i am importing something i can
just use add components for it and you
can think of this as really useful if we
were to do like
at system or something and you wanted to
just do
or or for example at design system slash
buttons and that lets you avoid doing
something like dot dot slash
that slash dot slash whenever you're
importing something it's
it's really really nice to be able to uh
do these kinds of absolute imports
um i also did the same thing with styles
i added some global base styles so i
have
a styles folder the global base styles
basically just do some
normalization and nothing much beyond
that
and there's a page here called
underscoreapp.js
these two are the the main ones that you
will always have in an xjs application
your index.js which is your homepage
and then underscore app.js this is where
you add anything global
and this is also where i'll say that
there are caveats
with next.js's router because in the
pages directory that's where you can add
as many routes as you'd like
you can add a page in here by just doing
new file and then
contact.js and i could copy the index.js
over into contact right here and rename
it contact
and i'll say contact me
like this and then if i were to save it
and then over here go to slash
contact then we got contact me
hey and so it's that simple to add a
route
that being said whenever you want
anything global it has to go through
this underscoreapp.js
and so that's where these global styles
are coming from um
and so if for example you want to share
state across your application
you could do it in a context right here
and so i could do a react
context and then wrap this component
like this
and then voila you have a context that
is shared across your entire application
and that's how that works
the caveat is if you wanted to only
share
state across like two routes you can't
uh if you if you wanted to share it
across like four routes out of ten
you can't you have to share it across
all of the routes um and that's the
caveat with
with the with the router it wraps the
entire application in there
and so that that's just that's just
something to know um
so you might look at this and be just
like oh yes this is a regular react
component
there's nothing fancy in here and that
is where you're wrong there are a couple
minor things that you can do um that
that can make a big impact and that's
because
page-based components are very different
from regular react components and so
right here this is just
a header again that takes in text but
when you look at the index.js
a page component is actually it's a
react component in this part
but everywhere outside of this is
node code and so when you do when you
want to
for example do something related to
querying data or something you would be
using
node fetch code outside of this actual
function right here
and i'm actually going to show you a
more complex example and we can
implement something together
but i'm going to go to my github really
quick and i'll paste a link
and then inside of here i'm going to
find my next
pranks repository so this next
pranks repository i actually um i gave a
conference talk on this and and
um it talks about it in here but in this
next pranks repository
um i use some of that node code and this
uh
activates some of that incremental
static regeneration that i mentioned
before
as well as some other fun things and so
in this prank i could be like
cassidy totally nailed this
presentation and then i generate this
link
and then this link when i click on it it
says
it rick rolls you and you didn't expect
to be rick roll today did you
um and then it also says cassie totally
nailed this presentation
not you've been pranked and it generates
a news page
and it's pretty fun and what's what's
interesting about this application
is it does that kind of node code side
of everything
but um it it does a little bit more with
dynamic routes and everything and so
i'm going to talk through it a little
bit so first of all you see the home
page
which is very very similar um to the
index.js that i showed you before
it has some state which state it's it's
react state nothing particularly
uh different in there it uses next link
i'm going to zoom in a little more so
you can see with next
link it's again it's just wrapping an
anchor tag and so it generates a new
link
to for users to go to um
people are privately dming me i didn't
expect to be rick rolled in a webinar
well you're welcome um and then also
uh you notice i have a
folder called news right here you can
see that
in the route it's very very small i'm
actually going to paste this in the chat
so you can
look at this yourself when you have a
folder it's just slash
news and that's what shows up in the
route and then it has this cassidy
totally
nailed the presentation you might notice
this
uh file name right here is in brackets
when it's in brackets that means it's a
variable and you can pro
programmatically change that and so
cassidy totally nailed this presentation
matched this variable right here inside
of here we have two
functions that are worth noting get
static paths and get static props
and those are the big node functions to
know inside of page
components get static pads means
whenever you query something in here
that'll generate all the paths that are
possible
to be rendered in a next.js application
so for example if you have a cms
and you wanted to um have blog posts and
you wanted all of your blog posts to
just
be the the pages that exist in there you
could call a fetch call inside of this
function
and then you would populate this paths
directory or this pads array with
with all of the strings that you want
because i have an
empty array that means that it's just a
variable i don't have any predefined
paths
it's just going to be a free for all
this fallback is true
means that if it's not inside of here we
don't return a 404 if this were false
then it would 404 if it was outside of
this
this pad saying and i have more examples
on this that i'll talk about
get static props is something where it
actually passes props to the page
component
um and so what i'm doing in get static
props is i'm getting the parameters
of the url i'm i'm converting it to a
title so that way it can be
the title of the article and added to
the head of this application
um and then with that i'm then passing
it
to the article and it's generating the
the rick roll and everything like that
and so this is this is where your node
code lives in get static pads and get
static props
i'm going to show you another example um
and this one is called next adventure
someone mentioned redux um i'm i'm not
going to be showing redux but i will be
showing
um x state and and state machines to
in this particularly uh particular
example
um and so this is an application that i
made for halloween called a lonely
code-filled night
it's spooky um and this was a
particularly interesting application to
build because it uses a bunch of
different technologies
so first of all it uses xstate for state
management
and i make a choose your own adventure
story with xstate and i made i made a
story which i will show you in a second
it also uses
react uh or netlify forms
and it's a react form uh with netlify
and it pushes to a hasura database and
so
in the choose your own adventure story
that i talk about um you can create a
character here and i'm actually going to
i'll put the url um i'll put the url in
the zoom chat so you can check it out
so when you create a character you can
put your name you can add the pronouns
you can put the character's favorite
smell that comes up in the story
and then you can put your email then
when you click this send button
what it does is it triggers a serverless
function that then populates a hasura
database
which then randomly populates a story
and so this story is uh it's different
every single time
with the different characters that are
coming from the database don't abuse it
please
um and it says once upon a time there's
a developer named narwhal who's working
very late at night very late at night
on halloween and then it's it says
narwhal decided to take a break to get a
snack he went to the kitchen couldn't
decide what to eat
we can decide to eat an apple or eat
some candy
i'm going to say we eat some candy he
munched on the candy
then he heard trick-or-treat that i
could outside we're going to either
ignore the kids or answer the door
i'm going to answer the door he opened
the front door but no one was there
it was very very spooky but it was
probably good because he ate the last of
the candy
we'll ask if anyone's out there he
called out in the night who's there
suddenly a werewolf comes up and said
have you heard of typescript and eats
him
the end um and so this is a very very
detailed story as you can imagine um but
what's cool about this is uh is how it's
implemented
and not to brag about my own code but
it's kind of neat and so in the pages
first of all there's the underscore
app.js that i talked about in that
underscore app.js we have the global
styles
but we also wrap the entire application
in a react
context and this react context is
something that i put in a context folder
and that shares the state across the
entire application
the other pages are there's the make
your own page and then in this make your
own page that's where we have the form
that i talked about
and it's otherwise a very very simple
custom form there
and then we also have a success.js this
is a page that shows up whenever you
make
a new character and then index.js also
just
navigates between the different pages
those ones aren't as interesting
i'm going to show you next the context
because the context has some very
interesting elements to it so first of
all an app context this is creating a
react context that
pulls in um a character which is pulling
in from that
uh character database that i that i
mentioned in hasura
and uh we generate a random character
that we then pass
to the rest of the application and then
that character is the thing that is used
in the story
um for the rest of context we have a
state machine and this state machine is
generated with x state
and it is kind of uh it's kind of hard
to
pull in all of the code into your brain
right now because it's big
but uh what's nice with xstate is it
actually has a visualization so you can
draw out the tree that you want in in
their visualization library and then
turn it into code and so i have all of
these
first levels of the story where where
you start the story and then there's the
first level
sorry the second level the third level
you can go deeper but this is this is
how that works
and then i generate a state machine and
so for every single state
i have the the starting value and then i
have the story
and then every time you click to a
different thing so the
the first button there was going to the
kitchen now there it goes to the story
and then there's two different states
that it can go to and then it goes out
into a tree
it gets fairly complex as you can see it
the
the code is long for generating this
whole story um but that that's that's
how it generally works
um and then at the end i create the
state machine and i pass it to the react
context that we talked about um one
other thing that
that was just kind of interesting was i
made a pronoun generation library in
here
this is not next.js i just thought it
was kind of fun um
where when a person picks a masculine or
feminine or non-binary pronouns
it then passes that to the different
story
portions so that way it can be correct
with the character that is passed in
so anyway once we've made this state
machine we pass it via context to the
rest of the application
then we can go to back to our pages and
we have this
s folder right here this s folder is the
story
now this is a more funky file name again
where it's in the brackets
but also it has dot dot dot in it and so
it has dot dot dot story
that means that yes it's a variable name
but it also can be spread
and so when we navigate through the
application if you were to go through it
snack time
we'll eat an apple this time the path in
there i'm going to paste it in the zoom
chat so you can see a bit more
um you can see how it has slash s which
is the
the folder name start which is the start
of the story then snack time
then eat an apple because it has that
dot dot dot
in the file name it spreads it out and
so you can have as many paths matching
that as you want
and still if you want to define those
kinds of pads you
you would use the get static props and
populate those pads
um but in this particular case it's just
so that way we can keep track of where
we are
in the story and so inside of here
i i have the story block which pulls in
the text from the state machine
and then whenever you click the button
what it does is it uses that use router
hook that i told you about that
that next router api right here
um it pulls in the router and then it
basically
makes a little bit of a redirect and so
it does a router.push and so for every
single
uh page in the story phase of the story
however you want to call it
it adds it to to the different pages and
so you can the
this is actually a very small component
it's it's
less than 60 lines of code um but this
powers the entire story
with uh with that x state um library
and so it's it's it's pretty interesting
what you can do
with these pages that are
a combination of everything the way that
i did this
this is actually client-side routing to
all of the different pages of the story
but at the same time it's also
statically generated
because we statically generated the home
page as well as the make your own
character page the success page
and then just the the kind of shell this
this uh
dot dot story page we statically
generate that
that individual page but then we
client-side generate all of the other
components in there because of how the
link works and because of how the router
works
it's it's kind of funky to wrap your
mind around i admit even making this
this demo i was kind of like oh so if i
do it this way
this will server side render that page
but if i do it another way it'll
client-side render it
it kind of combines the all three of the
worlds of client-side rendering
uh static site generation and
server-side rendering
all into one framework which which is is
very very powerful
and so for example let's just say i
wanted to make some kind of catalog
of content i could theoretically pull in
a page
statically have a database and then
client-side search through
uh the directory and have it all live in
one giant code base
um and so i i mentioned this uh codebase
before i'm going to
paste it in there um i saw that there
were there were some
questions about testing this particular
application i didn't test
probably should have but i would
probably use either jest or react
testing library for it
um so anyway if you wanted to query an
api
you would use something like that uh
that gets static props and
and get static pads i want to be aware
of time i think i have
a little bit of time to to query
something and so
we can do that really quick does anybody
have any questions while i uh
get ready to query something i want to
make sure that i
get questions answered
okay i'm gonna keep going in and so
let's just say i wanted to query an api
right here um i actually have a gist
i'm going to pull up my gist on github i
have a gist where i query pokemon
somewhere
there's a pokemon api that is nice and
simple to use
i'm going to search pokemon yours
i guess i don't that's fine i'm just
gonna go to uh
pokeyapi.co
and we have the pokemon api here so we
can we can query that pokemon api
and and i can show you what that can
look like in next.js and so let me pull
up my starter again
and so let's just say inside of contact
um
instead of contact i'm going to rename
this to pokemon
and then in pokemon.js i'm going to do
uh export async
function get static
props and then in here this is where i'm
going to fetch the pokemon api
and so it's going to be this https pokey
api
let's do what
response equals
a weight fetch
and then in here and then i'll do
charmander for now
okay so in here what we want to do is we
want to return an
object that has props and then props
will have
response right here and that response
can be pokemon
uh and we'll pass it right here and i
might need to do some parsing um
but we'll start with this now this is
this is the part where i wanted to talk
again about the the node and the
react stuff inside of this this is just
react inside of this this is node and so
if i were to do for example
console.log response right here
um what will then happen is
let me actually restart my dev server
and then refresh the page
oh i gotta actually go to slash pokemon
okay oh it's yelling at me this is fine
um when i when i do that it's this is
giving me a node error
it's it's it's console.logging down here
and not
console.logging in the browser um
and this is my own fault i probably
should have prepped my api call before
doing this
this part of it which is fine um
one second
i think i have it written down somewhere
yeah i'm just gonna copy some of this
really quick
on my monitor and then paste it over
here
okay
now if i were to do
a response
okay pokemon is not defined oh that's my
own fault again
ah sorry about this again i
needed to copy and paste this oh i need
to call.json thank you
you're right i'm going to
await and then.json thank you for that
the joys of live coding okay beautiful
okay look at that
we've got we've got the sprites we've
got the name of the pokemon we've got
charmander
all of that thank you for the json thing
i needed that um and so now
we can actually pass that to our page
okay so i'm going to inspect element
right here now again in the console we
have nothing
but if i were to do console.log
response right here now it's actually
going to be putting it
into the browser console and so this is
this is the
context thing i was telling you about
this is node this is react
this is where the browser is is doing
things this is where
node is doing things what's cool about
this though right now we're just
we're doing this as a developer we're
doing this as run dev
but this happens at builds time when you
deploy your site
and so if i were to deploy this site
somewhere i don't know why it's doing
this double a wait
i'm not going to question it right now
when we deploy our site all of the
fetches that we do
inside of here will happen at build time
that means when the person
who is going to your site accesses your
page
they won't have to wait for the pokey
api to return charmander
it's going to just work it's just going
to have the result of that api call from
builds time
and so it's super super performant when
you have a site that is
statically generated at builds time
where where you
make all of your api calls then and then
the user will just get
what is returned to the browser it
doesn't it doesn't care when those uh
those api calls happened it'll just
actually be be generated in there
the double weight is needed because of
promises oh yeah again
that's doing it live um and so we we
have this response like i could say like
instead of contact me
i could say something like
hello and then response dot
name and then look at that hello
charmander
and then we could pull in a sprite like
this and so if i wanted to do an
image tag i could do image src and then
in there i think it's response
dot sprite response dot sprites
dot front default
yes maybe save it try it yeah look at
that
we got charmander um and so we we could
do this with all of the different
pokemon
we could actually do this where if we
did get static pads
and turned this into uh the the square
brackets
we could generate a page for all of the
different pokemon
have that run at builds time and then
whenever a user goes to slash pokemon
slash charmander
pokemon slash pikachu so any of these
things
those pages will already be generated
and it'll just it'll just work
for them they don't have to worry about
the pokey api going down or something
because the pages have already been
generated um
if you have dynamic pass parameters can
you pass the values you want generated
at build time yes
yes that's exactly what get static pads
does and i'm trying to be aware of the
time because i want to get questions
answered i'm going to try this really
quick
and so in here i'm going to make a new
folder i'm going to call it
pokemon and then inside of here i'm
going to have a new file and i'm going
to do
in brackets pokey.js
like this i'm going to copy all of the
code that we wrote in
here and put it inside of here and i'm
going to
rename this to nothing just to have that
there
um okay so now we have a 404 because of
that that makes sense
but now we want to be able to go to
pokemon and then this pokey.js
so what i want to do is i want to do
export async
function and then get static paths
and then inside of here is where i'm
going to get all of the different
pokemon names
and because i don't want to go through
too many api calls i'm just going to say
um we're going to return
this object in here and then paths we're
just going to have
three pokemon or say whatever pokemon
you like and i'm just going to put
charmander and then
ditto and then whoever says the first
pokemon
i will put it in there someone said
mudkip nice
okay cool wow there's actually so many
sure
i'll do it i'll do a few other ones
okay anyway i'll stick with these for
now so we get these we get these pads
that are passed
to the array and i'm also going to do
fallback is false because i want all
other pages to 404
outside of these pages now with these
paths i also need to do
slash pokemon and so it's actually going
to be slash pokemon
charmander this is something that i
think is a little quirky but
it's okay and so it's it's slash pokemon
slash all of these different things
and now inside of get static paths or it
gets direct props i get the params
and then the params will be that pokemon
name and then that pokemon name will be
passed
inside of here and so it'll be
params.pokey
i think we'll see if that's correct um
and so if i were to refresh the page now
oh it's
it's slash pokemon charmander
yay okay it worked and now if i did
pokemon slash
mudkip yes
it worked yay and so we're we're pulling
in pokey because that's the that's the
file name there
we're getting the different parameters
to pass to each of these and then
we're fetching all of that and so add
builds time
we're going to get these four pads
generated as well
as the response called at build time and
so our users
don't have to wait for the api to be
called they can just go to that page
is this feasible with large data sets
yes we actually i
don't know how much i'm allowed to say
because i don't know who which customers
are secret of ours but some of our
customers at netlify in particular who
do this exact thing
they generate there there was one
customer that we had recently that
generated 400
000 pages and because they did static
first static builds really really fast
if you don't have a lot of serverless
functions or anything you just want to
generate the pages and
and call the call them in these
functions we had one
customer that had thousands and
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of pages and
uh their builds time was i think four
minutes
for all of them and so that's really
that's really really not bad when you do
purely static and then if you if you
start adding more things like
serverless functions and more detailed
things you will get longer build times
but it's
totally feasible to be able to do that
um if you did want the user to load any
pokemon not just the four we define in
pads
um then actually i think i could do
fallback it's true and
i'm going to try this i'm going to say
mewtwo and see what happens
yeah it didn't like that that's fine
[Laughter]
um so we we do need to actually generate
so uh more of these because it'll be
upset
um so what i would do here if we wanted
any pokemon and not just
any of uh not just what's here um
because right now if i were to do
uh fallback is false it'll do a 404 if i
did mewtwo otherwise it errors out
what we could do is we we have to do a
bit more validation
um but you could query the pokemon api
right here
and then just get all pokemon names i
have a demo of this somewhere but i
don't know where it is off the top of my
head um but you you would query all the
pokemon names that you want
you would still pass the to the pads
array and then you would get the params
the exact same way and get static props
okay i am now going to
stop sharing my screen and start
answering questions so that way we can
get all questions answered and i can go
back to showing code as needed but
i see that there are a lot of questions
here so i just wanted to check on that
really quick
okay so um
what happens if the requests change
after the after the build there's a few
things that you can do
um and there's actually a really good
case study on this on the netlife blog
that
was just released like last week um
because that
that one one of uh the customers that we
had
dealt with that um and it was a very
very interesting case study
uh i'm pasting it in the chat um
so what a lot of people do is they have
some kind of web hook
and so whenever the web hook is queried
it'll just
re-build the site with the new data um
but also one thing that we do with
next.js is
let's just say you want to do
incremental stack regeneration or you
want to do
server side rendered pages you can still
server side render those pages with
serverless functions
um and that's that's how we do it where
if you were to um
do some more server-side rendered pages
which um let's just say i did want to
not just query pokemon but query
something else or
or have some pages that aren't included
in the original build
um i mentioned before that i have a blog
post at cast.isr to talk a bit more in
detail on that
um you can do that and it'll just use a
serverless function to query it and
and so you can server side render those
pages if you don't want to wait for the
build every single time
that is a possibility um that being said
it's slower for your users and so it's
kind of like
you have to decide who who is more
important your your developer time or
your user time
there's no wrong answer there but that's
that's something to consider for that
um let's see how is the cache and
validation process or what are the
strategies around how specific assets or
pages work
look at my isr blog post because because
that that
answers some of the the caching things
we actually have some new things coming
out
next week around this particular subject
and so keep an eye out because i can't
talk about it until then
um but uh the the the cash validation
typically
when you do a new rebuild um it's an
atomic and immutable deploys and so
you'll get a brand new cache and a brand
new deploy
with every single one um
let's see if you don't have pokemon on
the paths we could use get server-side
props
yes yes you can so you can use get
server-side props once again that's
something that
works in next.js but it kind of moves
away from the
the static first approach that they've
been pursuing but get server side props
works and that's where you uh server
side rendered pages
uh with the uh serverless functions
um any tips on moving from create react
app to next.js
honestly create react app is great
because everything kind of lives
in a div you can move your entire create
react app
into an index.js on your next.js app
and including including your router
which will lead to some funky bugs but
you can
and then slowly move out all of your
different pages into
the pages directory it's a really smooth
transition process
depending on your application you might
want to decide if you want to do that
one one thing that i just want to note
is
again if you have if you have a large
context object or
a lot of state that you're sharing
across routes one of the things that i
like about
regular react is let's just say i'm
using react router i could wrap a
context around like three of my routes
and just share state around those routes
and that and
have it not affect any of the other
pages with
next your context has to wrap the entire
application which can lead to some
unusual re-renders and stuff
pros and cons pick your poison but
that's that's something to note there
you mentioned at the beginning of the
presentation that there are some set
advantages like seo could you explain uh
deeper end of it yeah and so that's
actually something that
um look a bit closer at that next
pranks application it's it's a silly
application but it uses some interesting
things under the hood and i'm going to
particularly send you to
this prankhead.js filed i just dropped
it in the chat
um with static sites and with
server-side rendered sites your seo is
greatly improved compared to
client-side rendered sites because the
pages are
built ahead of time um it's actually
best
seo is best on static sites next best on
server-side rendered sites
and worst on client-side rendered sites
but again it's kind of a spectrum of
things and
and uh seo is improved every single day
for
for developers who want to do all of
them um but in this particular file that
i sent
um you'll notice that i programmatically
update the title and i change the the
twitter card
and and uh the og images and everything
um that kind of stuff you can
programmatically change
in next.js really really easily this is
something that you can't do
as easily in a regular react application
and so your seo is greatly improved by
just being able to use that next head
api that lets you programmatically
update that
um let's see you're able to use all the
other react hooks right
right it's still just react it just adds
some structure to
to react but yes you can use all of the
other react hooks
and again you use them in the react part
of it
not in the node part of it you can't use
use effect and get static props or get
server-side props or anything
you do it in the components themselves
what can you tell us about deploying uh
what can i tell you about deploying i
don't know what what questions you have
but
actually i'll i'll pull up my next
starter application for example
um and and show you a little bit about
how that works
one second i will share my screen again
and so here's here's for example where i
deployed this project right here
um if you want to see generally how it
works first of all your domain name
appears here whenever you whenever you
deploy
it builds and then publishes and you can
see that you can look at the logs
for that particular deploy and see what
things might have gone right what things
might have gone wrong what warnings you
might have
it goes into pretty solid detail on that
um and then also there's a there's a few
different things that you can do
once you have deployed um you can change
uh your domain name
um and so you can change your your site
name here and
add whatever custom domains that you
want um
you can roll back to any other previous
deploys that you have you can add any
builds plugins
we automatically at netlify install this
essential next.js
you can uninstall it if you want but you
won't want to
um all of your serverless functions
happen here netlify identity is is
something for
for logging in and out if you wanted to
drop in
logging in and out to your application
and authentication
i have a blog post on that netlifeforms
this is what i mentioned
um that i use in the next.js adventure
of
application i added nullify to the form
and it automatically pulls in all the
form data
you can do split testing and that
automatically lets you do a b testing
across
different branches that is that is the
high level summary about deploying that
i think i can tell you
i don't want this to just be an ad for
nullified it's more about next.js but
that's uh if you have questions about
that i'm happy to answer them
um let's see not a question i want to
say this is amazing
thanks jose um do you actually recommend
to skip an independent server and make
all the next.js from projects that fit
in adrian i'm not entirely sure what
your question is asking would you mind
rephrasing it
um let's see what is the best way of
creating a multilingual application with
next
um so next does have a thing called next
internationalization
um and so you they they actually have
that built into the framework
that being said i think that there's
some better internationalization
libraries out there
and so i i personally use uh other
internationalization libraries rather
than the one built in just because
there's some
funky bass path things that can happen
um but
yes you can you can do that built into
the framework
um you mentioned that the requests to
the api are made during build time what
happens if the api response
changes um i kind of answered that
before
that you can either server side render
it every single time so it'll it'll run
on a serverless function or you can
rebuild the site and have a web hook or
something when the api response changes
i'm confused is next.js only for static
sites it can be used for static or
server side rendered sites it's fastest
on next sites or on static sites though
and so i tend to recommend that because
i like
the speed of the static ones
um what's the difference between react
server side render and next js good
question react server components
are very similar um we actually
i i don't know where the demo is
otherwise i'd send it to you
we made a an interesting demo with it
basically a server
component is still experimental so don't
bank on it
i i have regular meetings with the react
team and
they're all kind of like you know server
components are kind of an r
d we might throw them away but they're
they're we're all trying so
don't go all in on server components yet
uh
there there's still a lot of changes to
be had there that being said
um with server components they can be
run at builds time
to for static sites or at on uh server
side rendering things
next js provides a framework for
react and for doing that sort of thing
and they will probably implement
react server components um but react
server components are
it's it's basically just a separate
library from from next.js
at this point um next we'll probably
implement them but
it's a separate thing i hope that
answers your question
um if you're using typescript will the
react function recognize the typing what
gets tagged props returns
yes i am not a typescript developer
but yes it it pays attention to that
sort of thing and
uh you can do full typing in inside of
the get static prop stuff
um connect just handle pi time hope so
um coming from a view in next background
i'm really liking all the stuff the
react community is is coming up with
yeah and and honestly next for view
is kind of the same as next for react um
i've i've heard that next actually has
better
a uh api support and everything and and
does a lot of of
cooler things but i haven't used it
enough to be able to say if that's true
but
they both generally do the same thing
next and next
just if you prefer view or or react
um let's see does using less or sas
require extra config less does not
sas does require node sas because of the
weird
pages thing that i told you about how
it's like kind of node kind of
react and it's a combo of both you will
need to install node sas for sas
um but that's it it's just npm install
node sas and it'll work
um let's see if you have an api call
that changes a lot and create a static
page from it how do you refresh the data
from that static page
i would say it depends on what that api
is for myself i tend to
statically generate the page as much as
possible
but then if there's specific parts of
the page that require that i actually do
a lot of client-side rendering
of of those individual things and just
have a util for that
i think it's very okay to use all three
of
client-side server-side and static site
generation
and and mix them all together and figure
out what is
most performant for you um i think
client side is is still a perfectly
valid way of
doing things and and again it depends on
on what you want to do because
you can just keep regenerating a static
site depending on how big your site is
um there there's one and let me see if i
can find it
there's uh
i just totally messed up i was looking
at my co-worker phil but i just looked
up the name
phil instead of phil hawksworth which is
a very silly thing to do
um but he made a very cool site
called virtual lollipop and i'm going to
paste it in the chat here it's
vlolly.net and
um he generates the site every single
time and it generates really fast like
15 seconds
super super fast and it generates a new
page every single time and and it's
really interesting
it's okay to continually generate your
your
pages you just want to kind of decide
how much you want to do that and and
sometimes i like to save the build time
and save the server time and just do
client-side rendering things but it's
it's really
up to you how you want to do that and
some next js projects i've always get
the use
remove unused javascript in google
lighthouse
is that because of next that's
interesting because
next automatic code splitting should be
able to remove a lot of that
um so i'm not sure if that's because of
next
and i'm sorry that i can't help you with
that
um i think we are out of time but
thank you so much for for all of your
questions i am happy to answer more of
them i'm also going to be live streaming
in a few hours
um and so if you have more questions
then um i
live stream on thursdays at twitch uh
tv slash kassadoo and so i can answer
more questions there if you have them
but
thank you all so much for your time it
was really fun chatting with everyone
thank you very much cassidy for being
once again at white zone academy
for your time and for sharing your
knowledge with the entire community
and for the entire community thank you
very much for being here today
don't forget to fill out the feedback
survey get a chance to win a 30
amazon card it is very important for us
and for cassidy as well to help us
improve
see you in our future events and have a
wonderful day everyone
thank you thank you so much thank you
for having me
you